[Music]
[Applause]
all right
matt joined espn in february and
contributes across several shows
including get up
nfl live and he joins us on the program
all right matt
so we're not supposed to read too much
into these pro days but everybody's
reading into these pro days
you want to start with mac jones and his
disappointing pro day or justin fields
with his unbelievable pro day
yeah dan i've been doing this long
enough to know that these things really
don't matter they just give us something
to talk about
in the month of march you know it's like
there's a little bit of tournament
it's starting to die down let's talk
about pro days let's get excited about
guys throwing in shorts
or running 40s when that doesn't really
matter like you said so
i don't know that i want to put too much
into mac jones overthrowing
a couple passes and bill belichick
shaking his head or kyle shanahan
looking bored
as opposed to justin fields and who was
there who wasn't there
i would hope that in a time where we
should be better at evaluating
quarterbacks than we've ever been before
we would go back to who was actually
good from labor day
to new year's day and to me that was
justin fields and he's done it for two
years
never losing a game in the big ten zack
wilson
is he's impressive i was at the pro day
friday he is impressive
probably the most fun quarterback
prospect to watch this year but he did
it in the mountain west
in a week schedule and if you go back to
2019 11 touchdowns to nine interceptions
when you actually had to play someone
from the pac-12 which is like the fifth
best football conference so
i'm i'm not all in on the pro days
mattering that much
hopefully it just reminds people who
these players actually are
what are your quarterback rankings right
now yeah well trevor lawrence is one i'm
not dumb enough to argue against that i
i
have justin fields number two which is
funny because these two have been
competing for that top spot since they
were sophomores in high school
then i would say that zach wilson and
trey lance are very comparable
in terms of there's a lot of wow factor
there but there's a lot of boom or bust
potential because we haven't seen them
do this
against decent competition even and it's
small sample sizes with trade lines
then i have mac jones smith i know he's
the belle of the ball right now and
we got the tom brady comparisons out
there that's wild to me that we're going
to do that for a guy who's played 17
games at alabama
he's never not thrown into a first round
or a wide receiver he's got an
all-world offensive line in front of him
a first round running back
and an offensive coordinator good enough
to get the texas head coaching job so
it's just hard to look at that and not
feel a little mitch trubisky-ish
one year and we're blown away by the
football iq
and the upside and we we forget to
actually watch what these guys can do at
the position
okay do you think the niners moved up to
get mac jones
absolutely i do which as a as a lifelong
niners fan that's such a punch to the
stomach and
i'm trying to trust john lynch and kyle
shanahan but i remember when they said
they didn't need a quarterback
and they passed on patrick mahomes and
deshaun watson only to pick up cj
beathard in the third round
so i'm still i'm still a little gun shy
about trusting this front office
and it this just feels like something
they would do they would overthink it
again just like
trading back to get solomon thomas or
drafting reuben foster in the first
round
it just it feels like this front office
is a little too cute sometimes but matt
did the niners have to do this
to get mac jones they didn't have to go
to three dan
i don't think they did now maybe to
seven maybe to six which we saw that
pick get traded already
but i don't think you needed to go from
12 to three to get mac jones i don't
think the atlanta falcons
with arthur smith is going to look at
mac jones be like coming from ryan
tannehill that's the quarterback i want
i feel like the falcons would be all in
on justin fields who's a local kid
trey lance who has great athleticism
throws a beautiful deep ball
if they even go quarterback the bengals
aren't drafting a quarterback at five
the eagles weren't going to at six
so the niners had other options so my
hope and prayer
as someone who's still a little bit of a
49ers fan is that that is a move for
justin fields and i would say that even
as an
unbiased evaluator kyle shanahan i
understand loves matt ryan and kurt
cousins
look at who's beat you patrick mahomes
josh allen
russell wilson what do they all have in
common and it's mobility
not that mac jones is a statue back
there but you want plus level mobility
justin fields ran a 4-4
230 pounds and has a great arm i
just i don't understand why they would
overthink this but sometimes
we see too much of you know one of these
draft prospects matt
and you know desean watson the player
we saw too much of him and it felt like
we we we love the guy that we don't see
like daniel jones mitchell trubisky
we love the mystery here instead of
what's right in front of us
without a doubt i call it prospect
fatigue i can remember an nfl general
manager telling me
nick bose is not that good i was like
you're insane man
it's just you're just looking at the
fact that we've seen him play for three
years nick burst is one of the best pass
rushing prospects ever but
we get to this point of the cycle where
we're all a little bored
we all want that tweet that's gonna get
a lot of clicks we all wanna you know
hit the scroll on the bottom of the
screen with our takes
instead of i wish there was this moment
where we could just catch our breaths
and say okay
where were we december 31st on these
guys and unless something happened in
terms of injury or off field
or they show up to their pro day and
just they're 20 pounds overweight and
can't run
let's go back to where we were december
31st who was actually good at playing
football but you're right we
we want the kyler murray who you know
the one-year guy we want
mitchell trubisky instead of deshawn
watson beat alabama single-handedly
patrick mahomes on a very bad texas tech
team
made them competitive in the big 12.
those are the things and why i look at
justin fields of
we've seen you do it for three years and
even this year he threw six picks
some of that was you know his offensive
line wasn't very good some of it was on
him
go back last year he didn't throw a pick
i don't believe until the end of the
season so
it's not that he's this turnover laden
quarterback he was a very conservative
passer
it does feel like the the collective
draft media this year
has decided justin fields is the guy
they're going to be down on he's matt
miller espn nfl draft contributor
what happens now leading up to the draft
that may
change what happens with the draft order
you know i think the the biggest thing
would be like you mentioned deshaun
watson is off the table right now that
there's not going to be a trade there i
think sam darnold being moved
could affect the draft order but it
feels like we're locked in which i know
uh the bosses don't like right because
there's no drama and injury trevor
lawrence is gonna go first zach wilson's
gonna go second
it feels like mac jones goes third and
then you're on the clock at four
so it's you're an hour into the draft
before you're even like i wonder what
the falcons will do
and so unless atlanta trades out of that
spot there might be a little
intrigue there but you know sam darnold
being trade
traded could provide some clarity it
feels like the russell wilson stuff
unless he comes back on your show and
talks again and you know get some stuff
back on the trade market it feels like
those types of things have died down
where
we're really starting to settle into
knowing what teams want even
you know the rumors that joe burrow is
really advocating for jamar chase's
former teammate their pro days today at
lsu
you know even that you're starting to
say okay like picks one through five
you would feel pretty good about your
mock draft right now the best player
in this draft or best players give me
three regardless of position
yeah it's trevor lawrence he is the best
player in this draft and i love that
we've just stopped talking about him
because he's accepted he's going to go
first he's great
let's move on i think jamar chase is
second again the lsu pride is today we
haven't seen him play football in a year
which
i think some people looked at the 170
pound devante smith and started saying
that he was somehow better than jamar
chase
jamar chase is 40 pounds heavier he's
gonna run faster in the 40
and he had 20 touchdowns as a sophomore
with joe burrow
third i would go kyle pitts and i don't
even want to put a position on kyle
pitts he's an offensive weapon
she's a pass catcher at florida their
pro day is today as well i think he's
gonna run in the four
mid four four range at six foot five 245
pounds
he was unstoppable last year at florida
he and kyle trask had a
beautiful connection and the ability to
high point in the red zone
to win over the top reminds me of mike
evans so i'm not even comparing this guy
to a tight end he's just someone who
in the red zone could be a huge
difference maker
if i had last year's quarterbacks in
with this year's quarterbacks
who would be the number one overall pick
it would be closer than i think a lot of
people realize but i do think it would
be trevor lawrence just because the
three years that we've seen you know
taking over the job from kelly bryant as
a freshman
we've seen it sustained for a while with
joe burrow there was even people last
year
like maybe tua is the best quarterback
maybe justin herbert is because with joe
it was the
one-year wonder you know that joe brady
gets there everything becomes perfect
and he has the best quarterback season
i've ever seen in college football
but i do think lawrence would be one
borough would be too i think there the
conversation is
interesting the injury to tua would
probably put zach wilson ahead of him
might even put justin fields ahead of
him and then we would probably see tua
and justin herbert who was over thought
a lot like i think justin fields is
being overthought
but it's crazy the league feels like
it's changed in the last just year
where mobility is so much more valued
now than it was
even in in march of 2020 yeah but drop
back quarterbacks have been winning
super bowls
well that's just tom brady right right i
mean
like tom brady's been winning super
bowls you know otherwise it's it's
mahomes it's rogers it's wilson so
you know we have to you almost have to
play but mobility equation
mobility is is you know it's kind of in
the eye of the beholder because
i like mobility you know i don't i don't
need to have somebody who is
i need you sliding in the pocket i need
you getting outside the pocket
uh you know mahomes was isn't a fast guy
i mean right his 40s
mobility not a runner yeah being able to
move to throw
not move to run i'm with you on that and
i i do think that
to some degree that might hurt justin
fields and trey lance is that they were
asked to run a decent amount
especially justin fields was at georgia
as a true freshman
jake fromm was the quarterback and he
would come in and run qb power
and so i think that that is affecting
their stock a little bit where
zack wilson moves to throw mac jones
moves to throw even though
i think a hundred drop backs was all he
was pressured in his 17 start so there's
not a big sample size of that but
it's not his fault that alabama has
first rounders at every position on the
offensive line
have you ever loved a quarterback and he
didn't pan out when's the last time that
happened
uh yeah that happens all the time in
this job i love teddy bridgewater i
watching teddy at louisville was like
this is this is it this he's accurate
he's smart tough and just let him you
know let him work off reads on guys
that's not a bad one though matt because
i i loved him too
but you know without that injury you
know i i really
and i liked the character of teddy
bridgewater too
same and he didn't have a good pro day
but i just said you know put on the tape
when he played miami he gets hit right
in the mouth
you know exactly like that's what i want
to know with these quarterbacks
what do you do when there's adversity
well that's the huge part that's huge
that's one of my big keys in my scouting
reports is
adversity and it's like justin fields
gets rocked by clemson
i would still be laying on the field
crying at that zack wilson even there's
some adversity there he had two injuries
in college they told him before the year
is an open job this job might not be
yours next year so i think you can look
at those things and you want some
adversity
but then again like peyton manning and
andrew luck two of the greatest
quarterback prospects ever
arguably no adversity so you have to
like you have to almost look for it
sometimes yeah trevor lawrence has been
the number one pick probably since he
picked up a football as a sophomore in
high school
and you know there's some credit to that
too that you've been in that spotlight
since you were 16 years old
and you've been a great leader you've
been a great captain on your team he's
already engaged he's super mature
so there's something to be said for that
too hypothetical
if peyton manning coming out of college
andrew luck coming out of college
and trevor lawrence coming out of
college and he got the first pick
i'm going to give you what you already
know about luck and
clinton and the unknown with trevor
lawrence
who would matt miller espn nfl draft
contributor take
number one overall
oh i'm taking peyton manning you can't
go against even
even in today's game he's just too smart
carves up the field
and the accuracy at all levels and i
think peyton was sneaky athletic early
in his career deceptively fast i think
that's that's what we have to call it
but he could move around a little bit it
wasn't it wasn't quite as bad as it was
in the denver days
okay so yeah i thought you might go
trevor lawrence you know recently
i'm not trying to get this clipped out
in five years and people be like this
idiot actually thought trevor lawrence
is better than peyton i'm
i'm not doing that well done matt well
done hey uh
congrats on the job and uh we'll be
watching and thanks for joining us
yeah i appreciate it dan thank you
that's matt miller espn nfl draft
contributor